a show's villain is as important as its
hero but that doesn't mean we always
know who the bad guy is right away
here's a spoiler-filled list of the best
bad guy reveals in tv history
when lost arrived in 2004 there wasn't
much like it on the small screen it
featured an enormous cast and brought
over 18 million viewers to abc the
highest ratings for an offering on the
network in almost four years one thing
the show didn't have however was an
honest-to-goodness villain the survivors
of downed oceanic flight 815 had to
weather some pretty singular adversities
there was the smoke monster of course
and the everlasting conflict between
anti-hero sawyer and well everyone else
but lost was missing a true big bad all
that changed however when actor michael
emerson showed up as the mysterious
henry gail in season 2. some of the
members of the group felt henry's
stories about arriving on the island in
a hot air balloon and losing his wife in
the subsequent crash were a bit too neat
to be true
so in the season 2 episode lockdown the
oceanic survivors go looking for answers
they find a balloon and a grave but
henry's wife isn't in it the real henry
is when the phony gale is called out for
the falsehood emerson really shines in
the role he seems to morph into an
entirely different person ben linus in
the blink of an eye this manipulative
antagonist would go on to wreak havoc on
the island in the following seasons
finally giving lost a true villain
the inaugural season of true detective
follows two investigators played by
matthew mcconaughey and woody harrelson
on the hunt for a serial killer
throughout the season the show's writer
and director expertly build the
expectation of the evil we'll encounter
when we meet our villain the
protagonists escalating run-ins with
voodoo kidnapping cover-ups and violent
meth dealers signal that whatever is
waiting at the end won't be pretty
at the end of season 1 episode 7
audiences are finally clued into the
killer's identity and it's an almost
forgettable groundskeeper from way back
in episode 3. in the hands of a lesser
creative team the moment might have felt
like a lazy callback
not so here by the time deranged killer
errol childress appears casually giving
two other police officers directions
from his lawnmower viewers have
witnessed a laundry list of evil deeds
the dread of confronting something much
worse than what the two leads have
previously encountered is as thick as
louisiana's humidity as errol watches
the police officers drive off and the
creepy music starts to play we see scars
on the lower part of his face consistent
with descriptions of a suspect
revelatory moments like this one really
marked the slow burning first season of
true detective for greatness the closing
moments of after you're gone dare the
audience to keep watching and almost
make viewers hope harrelson and
mcconaughey stay at home
stop really man stop i don't wanna
hear it
for much of the flash season one
harrison wells acts as the kindly genius
founder of star labs he supports barry
allen's efforts as a superhero and
serves as his mentor over the course of
the season however his character begins
to act increasingly strange and flash
and his respective allies suspect
something is off a stinger in episode 9
shows the audience that harrison is in
possession of reverse flash's iconic
suit but the show doesn't confirm the
worst until episode 15. by that point
most of team flash suspect wells is the
yellow speedster but not everyone is
convinced
unfortunately well's surrogate son cisco
finds out the hard way after cisco
discovers where wells hides the suit in
the previous episode wells confronts him
admitting that he not only had a hand in
barry's mother's death but is actually
eobard thon flash's all-time big bad
anyone wondering why wells might
announce his secrets so bluntly gets
their answer when wells follows his
monologue by killing cisco this moment
where thon admits his sins and kills a
character his alter ego cared about
cements the villain's full arrival and
the scope of his malevolence and it
happened in the first episode back from
the show's mid-season break giving fans
a compelling reason to keep tuning in
marvel's wand division kicks off when
the scarlet witch finds herself married
to a newly risen vision in an idyllic
sitcom-style existence
viewers watch as wanda tries to embrace
her new life but slowly discovers
something's amiss
all isn't what it appears to be in
wanda's prime time network town
especially when it comes to her
neighbors
throughout the series wanda has kooky
and friendly encounters with a neighbor
named agnes played by a scenery chewing
katherine hahn like any sitcom neighbor
she's a bit snoopy but mostly kind until
the end of episode 7 while wanda takes a
day to recharge agnes looks after her
children
soon though wanda suspects she and her
family are in danger and goes to collect
her kids
where are the twins
agnes tells wanda the kids are playing
in the basement when wanda descends the
stairs she finds a witch's lair agnes
then walks into the room and introduces
herself as a fellow witch named agatha
harkness
as agnes invades wanda's mind the show
suddenly cuts to the song agatha all
along in one catchy tune agatha is
revealed to have been pulling wanda's
strings throughout the whole series and
worse she's killed wanda's dog the
number is a great showcase for han's
charisma and enormously raises the
stakes for the coming series climax by
introducing the main antagonist
who needs subtle reveals more theme
songs please
when westworld first premiered in 2016
its robo cowboy world building and
unique storytelling made it must-see tv
as the show confidently swaggered
through its time-bending opening season
it delivered twist after twist
one of the most devastating was the
finale's bad guy reveal in the show's
premiere audiences are introduced to
jimmy simpson's william and ed harris's
man in black
on first impressions the two stand in
stark contrast to one another william is
a meek but kind first timer in the theme
park and the man in black is a park
veteran who revels in doing horrible
things to its animatronic hosts as the
series unfolds it becomes clear that the
show's story is set in two distinct
timelines however since westworld was
co-created by jonathan nolan brother and
collaborator to the notoriously
confusing director christopher nolan
it's not always clear exactly which
timeline is which the show sets the
record straight when its protagonist
robotic host dolores played by evan
rachel wood encounters the man in black
in the series finale
he reveals that they've met before and
that his first encounter with dolores
helped him find himself
dolores remembers who he is calling him
william and the editors intercut his
monologue with sequences that show the
once gentle william becoming the evil
man he is now it's tragic that someone
so kind could wind up so vile but in a
pivotal moment to the show his gutting
reveal clearly establishes what's
present and what's past
not many detective shows leave audiences
as shaken as broadchurch did and all of
that is due to its villain reveal in the
show detectives ellie miller and alec
hardy are investigating the murder of an
eleven-year-old named danny like most
detective shows in the end the partners
get their man but by the time it's over
audiences and protagonists alike will
wish the villain had never been revealed
the show builds up our trust in
relationships by dedicating notable
attention to the supportive relationship
between ellie and her husband joe
so in the end when hardy discovers
ellie's husband joe is in possession of
danny's phone anybody watching prays
it's a red herring
but it's not a flashback reveals that
joe murdered dany because dany
threatened to expose their pedophilic
affair to the town it's awful on so many
levels and adds real bite to the series
focus on trust and secrets
the murder scene's frantic editing
showcases just how fast the threat of
exposure escalates things between joe
and his young victim once they find out
what happened viewers sit with turning
stomachs waiting for ellie to discover
her husband's secret only such a
powerfully depressing reveal can make
the audience hope one of the
protagonists never learns the truth
the hbo series watchmen has a bad guy
reveal that is quite different from its
graphic novel bad guy reveal when
viewers first meet lady true she's a
brilliant conglomerate-owning clone
maintaining scientist with a hidden
agenda however it's not clear just how
dark that agenda is until it's too late
at first the show's big bad appears to
be an organization called cyclops a
white supremacist group out to steal dr
manhattan's powers however when they
attempt their plot in the finale their
leader gets turned into a puddle and his
followers are teleported away to find
true waiting with an even larger evil
plan true reveals herself as the real
puppet master and the daughter of adrian
white the surprise villain in the comics
it's brilliant because it not only
connects truth to a character from the
source material but also connects their
murderous motives in the comics adrian
blew up manhattan to trick the world
into agreeing to world peace
in the hbo series true murders dr
manhattan in an attempt to subjugate the
world to her benevolent will the comic
and tv series are separated by decades
of cultural change but the latter's
villain reveal unites their central
questions about wielding immense power
over other people in the service of a
personal utopian vision
humanizing a murderer is tricky in any
medium but showtime's dexter managed to
do it for eight seasons and was
eventually revived for a knife the
show's premise that dexter is a serial
killer who only kills other serial
killers is a strong way to hook an
audience
as the show goes on however its
elaborate twists and turns prove it's
more than just an engaging hook during
season 1 the show fleshes out dexter's
healthy relationship with his adopted
sister deb it also establishes a rivalry
between himself and a serial killer
known only as the ice truck killer
so things get complicated when the
audience discovers that the man courting
deb is actually gasp the ice truck
killer himself in a reveal so casual it
demands an immediate re-watch deb
discusses plans for a date with her
suitor rudy rudy tells deb he needs to
wrap up some housework before coming
over after he hangs up the phone the
audience gets a look at what the work is
chopping and packing human body parts in
his walk-in murder freezer it's an
impeccable dramatic irony the viewers
know the truth about rudy but deb and
dexter remain in the dark for a long
time for the remainder of the season the
audience watches dexter and deb inch
closer to the truth and the danger and
the tension is tangible
dexter is engrossing entertainment and
moments like these cement its place in
great tv history
the villain reveal at the end of hbo's
sharp objects is probably the most
audacious on this list casting the
events of the entire show in a new light
sharp objects is based on jillian
flynn's novel of the same name yep the
same author behind gone girl another
story with a shocking villain reveal
hbo's mini-series follows crime reporter
camille preacher as she returns home to
wind gap missouri there she gets caught
up investigating the murders of some
local girls in between sleuthing she
navigates her complex relationships with
her mother adora and teen half sister
amma ultimately camille discovers
evidence suggesting adora killed the
girls and sends her own mother to prison
bleak stuff but this is a jillian
flynn's story we're talking about it can
always get a lot worse in the most
unexpected ways and moments before the
credits roll it does literally within
the show's closing minutes camille
discovers evidence hidden in amma's room
that suggests she was the killer all
along amma appears in the doorway sees
camille and whispers don't tell mama
the show hard cuts to the credits but
anyone trying to catch their breath is
acting too soon a mid-credits scene
shows amma definitively committing each
murder including that of a new friend
may sometime later after she and camille
move to st louis
it's brilliant and possibly one of the
most depressing endings ever committed
to the small screen check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]